welcome to this video part three of the
World Championship match appetizing
series presenting great games by anand
and carlsen was actually thinking a bit
about how to cover the serious best
games doesn't flee right it's always
difficult to say what games are the best
because it's a matter of taste and you
can easily if you do 10 games you can
easily overlook something and then
people write to me why didn't you do
this game so yeah it's so let's just
enjoy some great chess and not to argue
if some game should have been in their
arm or not it's also that I have covered
some games before especially if you
think about 2013 Tata Steel islands win
with black against our only honest one
of the all-time best game certainly of
islands and I have done this video
already so if you look for another
thousand on my channel you will find
plenty more games I won't do any double
coverage like doing a game again that I
did before ok let's go to UM the game in
hand for this video this is Alan plain
white against evil shook all of the best
players ever never to become world
champion and probably he never will I'm
still a formidable opponent always
putting a great resistant resistance and
tone let's see this game was played in
1996 in Las Palmas back then it was one
of the strongest tournaments ever maybe
in terms of ratings strongest ever okay
let's start on a place money for and we
got a ruler PES all very standard now
eventual plays Bishop c5 this is an one
version
of a complex of various lines where
black plays the Bishop to c5 you can do
this here on you five you can play this
first or sometimes like starts with this
and then plays Bishop c5 those this is a
bit special which would be seven ok this
is what Avant your plate and here white
has says many moves on a principled way
to combat this is to capture only five
and this is what i learned did and of
course instead of that and white could
also go for more standard approach like
lights III for example like like this
which after b5 from AI transpose to
something we looked earlier okay 95 and
of course the ideas often i takes to
play deform this this open not upside
this fog wide is going to get the piece
back and then this is some very typical
way of playing here even shock took on a
form instead turn there also are the
moves black can also play be five maybe
this is a wiser choice but okay this is
not his mistake 94 wasn't bad at all I
mean it's just another line and here I
don't play to rookie one attacking many
pieces now so it's clear that white will
get a piece back but he wants to use
this rook on this deal on e file I'm
directly across black skin yeah what
should like do needs to be cautious of
course if you if you do something like
that there's this capture and so the
light is gone so
caution is necessary here the most solid
way to play and probably best is Bishop
to e7 this is what a bunch of plate the
bishop is blocking this file and after
rook takes you four to retreat to g6 so
on what'n are the consequence of this
transformation the e-file is now open
and the rook is already on e4 but on the
other hand if we look at this let's say
c4 so what we she played councils 93 and
d6 this was played and we see that the
open e file is at the moment used by
white but this kind of position can
easily fizzle out with black playing at
st. bishop here we should have six and
then prepare for a low-key 8 and if the
rooks are traded on the foul there's not
much happening really so on this is a
fairly solid position for black now I'm
Adam starts very interesting operations
he plays Knight to d5 and the idea is
very simple um what just wants to take
the bishop and get the bishop pair so a
typical procedure would be something
like this okay why it just enjoys the
two bishops however the eventual can
play Bishop to h4 this is what it did
just securing this and the main idea is
if white plays the simple move g3 like
it's going to respond with c6 and this
is so quite annoying you don't want to
take here this would completely ruin
your pawn structure and your king
so we're not a good idea after g36 white
would need to retreat somewhere maybe
here and with this to come like it's in
good shape no problems at all especially
this Bishop is not very effective so I
this is rather no move c6 is a threat so
what did or didn't play plate Queen to
h5 and if you don't look at this too
closely you are not yeah you cannot
really appreciate what this move is
doing but of course the key point is c6
what would happen if white now retreats
the night let's say in black simply to
play b5 first attacking the bishop let's
say it retreats and then you near five
so black rhodium gets a number of moves
here that you can play with temple and
he activates his pieces nicely if what
needs to retreat this sword doesn't make
much sense so what did I on play it took
on h4 and this is a really amazing
concept first the simple tactic if the
night captures there's Bishop g5
attacking here so let's say something
like this and now after C txt five week
five check very important King h8 Bishop
d3 there's d6 falling and what will have
two pawns for the exchange and excellent
mr. bishops and central control so as
great position
right age for therefore it's not
playable at all so Queen takes and white
has sacrificed in exchange now and it
doesn't have really any choice queens
are traded must do that I now Knight b6
just attacking the rook and the night
now sits very nicely on the v6 square
here black has a key decision to make
and the one shall place them the human
move and probably is also the right move
also in terms of yeah probably call it
being being principled he played rugby
aid securing the rook um you could
return the exchange here if you like
with Bishop f5 just accept that this
night is a strong piece and return it
and something like this however it's the
slight advantage to white because of the
two bishops it just conceits something
returning the exchange so eventually
secured to secure the rook and now the
key point is Bishop f4 attacking here
like only has one reply Tony's got this
move look v8 is answered by a Bishop g5
just attacking two pieces only move and
now and this is very strong d5 not see
5c five looks good at first but it's not
really after the should be six keeping
the pieces passive so something like
this either cod4 hang but even even
something like this you will get this
pawn on d6 d4 d5 is much stronger
because it now completely kills the
queenside this night
here it's dominating the rook look
cannot move the bishop also cannot move
that cannot go to g6 this has just been
taken you cannot go to this happen
because of the night also if you look at
this night it only has got one duty a
very important one though covering the
porn while white it's just threatening
to increase the pressure here maybe
we'll see five maybe g4 at some point so
black is very very passive for the
exchange and white has definite
compensation and this is the amazing
thing about Allen's concept yeah it's
clear that when you played queen age 5
he had envisioned exactly this position
and exactly this position this is some
six moves dipped or five moves deep
however um and you really need to assess
probably that properly that you have a
sufficient compensation here very
remarkable accomplishment to foresee
this kind of compensation on the capital
of moves earlier in fact of you um it
gets more impressive if you look at the
next couple of moves the everything
works together just like um yeah just
like clockwork you can't replace rook to
e8 in fact you could analyze this game
very deeply of you if you want to and
before this serious I don't want to go
into much detail just want to present
the the outlines of the game enter
presented just mostly for for enjoying
enjoying the chairs are not analyzing to
too deeply and I hip like for example if
you want to put in more could have tried
group d 8 which is an interesting try
trying to get this Bishop moving at some
point that after c5 it gets very
complicated this is one thing you could
analyze if you if you like to it's
probably a playable line from like but
ok let's focus on what happened rookie
aid and in fact the reply now is again a
very strong move when you actually had
to foresee before and king of one and
why is this strong because rupee for was
blacks idea activating the look and in
fact this can be answered by a very
strong move and the movies rookie one
this is really strong now it's a matter
of a week back rank block has no choice
he needs to exchange now jack takes
otherwise rookie admit takes yeah and
now the problem is there is this threat
and it's a really big threat also there
c5 but cannot move any of its pieces in
fact them if you give this position to a
computer it wants to it wants to play
Bishop e6 and okay this means that white
is an excellent shape getting back a
bishop so looking for has the strong
reply but the bunch of data supplied h6
gets a bit of air for the king but it
seems that after after this move that
sir it's very difficult to to save um
it's however also very difficult to play
what should like do um
hard to tell and they have been there's
been some analysis on this game maybe an
idea that stuff is h5 controlling the
square and after that it's not so clear
how the game should proceed there are
various ideas one idea not the very
creative one especially to attacking
here to intensify the pressure and after
night deform we should pay for it could
end in a perpetual okay there are other
ideas what can also try to just improve
the position there are many tries to do
so taking is also possible of course but
this is not really in the spirit of all
this now Lex look is activated maybe h5
was stuffing after age six it gets
really really tricky and this is because
of again a very strong move on 83 this
prepares g4 and g4 is a very substantial
threat if the night moves Bishop t6 will
win huge chunks of material here black
is in deep trouble you played rocky four
and after that white simply retreats
this is another virtue of the smooth
it's just prepared a nice square on h2
ce5 and now the key move G for whites
pieces work together perfectly in this
game just think about all these pieces
there they're protecting each other and
they control so many important squares
if the night now moves the shop d6 will
just win a whole look and what should
like do he took on c4 which is probably
am the tougher
stir defense but it's probably already
beyond repair it takes and now again an
important point white could take the the
night Bishop takes you should be six but
there's room d 8 compared to the
compared to the game that's not bad for
white but compared to the game we played
rookie one first threatening rook to e8
and look 28 is such a substantial threat
that black only has got one move Bishop
to e6 needs to prevent the check on yet
with this deadly pending on the back
rank after that white took and now White
has won a whole temple which is you to
this position look check you know grab
let's check in g1 and rock the eighth
now on a child look II eight and
exchange rocks so how to assess this
position isn't this some player for
black he's got three pawns for the
bishop yeah i think this position is
some somewhere between a very large edge
for white and and the win in the long
run it will be very difficult for black
to keep the pawns the two bishops just
work together nicely the computer
nowadays isn't so confident about
White's position it gives white some
edge but not a flat-out win on I think
the computer is probably a bit too
pessimistic here especially if you look
at something like this which would be
six and a four this is something that
also black couldn't really prevent those
two pawns in connection with this
additional bishop basically control the
Queen side and then it's three against
one on the King side where with AB of
the king and further activation and
white at some point when
Paul it's not evident at the moment but
it will happen in the long run we can
advance a couple of moves check check
this a five pawn controls to pause and
now White has this idea to advance on
the kingside their flow it's not a
necessary move he just enters here and
now they are multiple ideas one ideas to
also attack this pawn but also Bishop to
f8 and in fact if you look at this
position chance after F for teenage to
there is no way to prevent Bishop to f8
and capturing the power lon h six so
this position even shocker already
resigned the real star move on the stark
concept of this game is the exchange
sacrifice let's go back to that because
I know that it deeply impressed me when
I first saw this rook takes and then we
get to this position with especially d5
very strong that this this configuration
of pieces together with the pawns really
completely completely stunts blacks
position cannot move any of those pieces
and this is a very good demonstration of
them of them compensation of that it's
not it's not entirely strategic because
there's always this g4 idea where it
gets very concrete
but it's almost a strategical
compensation where pieces are simply
wear pieces of a nominally lower value
like the night on b6 dominate higher
ranked pieces like this rook the night
is simply dominating this rogue and it's
a very nice concept to find especially
considering that you had to envision
this sequence and also envision a
counter play like rook rook e8 to hear
like like rook e8 rookie for with rookie
one so I'm a very very strong game
violence and in fact them it it was
quite bit more complicated than my brief
presentation maybe yeah made it look
like it here you could analyze it much
much deeper if you if you like to
especially blacks defenses black maybe
has some some way to defend this but
it's really really difficult to do so I
hope you enjoyed this game and maybe the
sum helps you to appreciate compensation
of a more strategic nature and I know
that this game deeply impressed me when
I first saw it yeah thanks for watching
and I'll be back soon with get another
part of this video series